en la última hora hemos visto aquí en
las afueras de Downey Street un desfile
constante de diputados del partido
conservador que van a entrar a reunirse
con el Primer Ministro richizunaki que
pueden entrar al gabinete este equipo de
richis una que es hasta el momento Y por
supuesto un grupo de aliados muy
cercanos de caras nuevas y de ministros
ratificados dentro de esos grandes
aliados está Dominic rap como lo
mencionabas ha sido designado nuevamente
como
dice Primer Ministro tuvo este cargo
durante el gobierno de Johnson y también
será el ministro de Justicia dentro de
los ratificados hay tres ministros hasta
el momento Jeremy Hunter el ministro de
finanzas esto para dar un mensaje de
tranquilidad a los mercados y porque el
31 de octubre el gobierno tendrá que
presentar y defender en el parlamento su
plan económico también James cleverly el
ministro
bastante de exteriores se contemplaba
que podría ser Penny Morgan quien
competía con Richi zonas para hacer
Primer Ministro cleverly es uno de los
grandes aliados y cercanos
ha sido ratificado como ministro de
defensa se especuló que porque había
dado su apoyo a Boris Johnson en las
últimas horas podría ser removido pero
esto es un mensaje importante para
Ucrania porque el Reino Unido como
política de estado ha decidido que va a
seguir apoyando a este país durante todo
el tiempo que dure la guerra con Rusia
como pueden ver ustedes mucho movimiento
a esta hora los grandes aliados de
listas y demores Johnson muchos de ellos
han salido ya del gobierno